[Classical music plays]
For thirty years, Miller
Theater has been a nexus of creativity and
experimentation here on the columbia campus,
and as we celebrate this milestone anniversary,
we honor the legacy of the arts at Columbia.
From landmark works by Martha Graham and Aaron
Copland and Charles Ives
that took place right here in this very building,
and also the bold, adventurous work that has
made Miller Theater what it is and what it
will be going forward.
and so, while we’re very excited about Miller
Theater being thirty, what’s even more exciting
is the fact that it ties this important legacy
of
the arts at Columbia University.
We open Miller Theater’s 30th anniversary
season with the very anticipated New York
premiere of
“Proving Up,” It’s a New Chamber Opera
from the creative team of Missy Mazzoli and
Royce Vavrek
Missy Mazzoli: Miller Theater has an amazing
history of presenting amazing work, and Columbia
has an amazing history of presenting new opera,
you know, all the way back to Virgil Thomson.
So I’m really thrilled that Miller is
commissioning this work, co-commissioning
this work and they’re one of the first presenters--
the first presenter in New York City and is
thrilled to be a part of that legacy.
Melissa Smey: So we’re commissioning six
new works for the coming season, the co-commission
of the chamber opera for opening night, we’re
commissioning two of the composers
in the composer portraits series, both
Wang Lu and Tyshawn Sorey
Tyshawn Sorey: In this portraits concert I’m
extremely excited to present a version that
will be commissioned by Miller Theater called
“Autoschediasms” for creative chamber
orchestra
I’m absolutely thrilled to present my
music here at home I would say, at Columbia
University.
Collaboration is at the heart of what
we do at Miller Theater, and it’s certainly
at the heart of my programming philosophy
and the way that I work with emerging artists
and ensembles, faculty, students,
and so we regularly partner, particularly
with faculty, on a variety
of initiatives at Miller Theater
for the coming season we’re going to be
collaborating quite closely with George Lewis
who’s composing a new work for us in a new
keyboard series that we have.
We’ve been honored to work in the past with
faculty including Professor Bob O’Meally
who’s a really key partner for us
in Morningside Lights, and it’s core to
what we do here
at Miller Theater, those collaborations.
Zosha Di Castri: So when my undergraduates
come to me and ask a little bit about where
to go see concerts in New York or how to sort
of get introduced to
music scenes, often I tell them Miller
Theater is a great place to start because
they have such a breadth of programming, they
have a lot of diversity of voices,
which I really appreciate, and they do a lot
of educational and outreach work too which
I think is great.
And so, you know, in classes where they’re
learning-- students are learning from
early music all the way to the present, we
really get that scope in the programming
MM: The composer portraits series is really
unique in that I think it’s the only series
of its kind in New York city, and it’s a
place where you can go to discover the newest
voices
and to hear really established composers in
a totally new context, and to hear them do
things that are maybe more risky or challenging
um, and to hear a lot of their work all at
one time
ZDC: Being featured on the portraits series
at Miller Theater was a big moment for me
having studied here in New York
I attended a lot of those concerts.
And I think for me it was also an important
moment to
sort of to believe I was doing this as my profession,
not just sort of as a student
TS: Columbia University and Miller Theater
represent a major transition in my development
as a composer
I’ve studied with both George Lewis and
Fred
and so Columbia University and Miller Theater,
they represent this trajectory, this trajectory
in which I’ve
advanced my compositional language
MS: so today Dodge Hall, the building that
we are in is the arts building on the Morningside
campus, it’s home to Miller Theater, it’s
also home to Columbia University’s school
of the arts,
but when it originally opened, it was home
to the business school.
And this space that we’re in now was Macmillan
Academic Theater and I think that legacy
of a commitment to contemporary music, you
know, it didn’t start with Miller Theater,
that’s been part of the core of the arts
at Columbia
going all the way back to the beginning of
this building which is so important.
And we’re thrilled really to honor the legacy
of the arts at Columbia University in the
work that we’re doing here.